it is cancer awareness night and a
special pregame ceremony
in honor of mike bell the twins bench
coach who passed away in spring training
at the age of 46.
as we begin this series against the
cincinnati reds
managed by mike bell's brother david we
felt it appropriate to once again
reiterate the impact that mike bell had
on the twins organization
during the two years he was part of our
staff before we share those sentiments
we are honored to have with us 13
members of mike bell's family
at the game this evening mike left an
impact at every stop of his baseball
journey
and the twins were fortunate to have
mike choose minnesota on that journey
we now invite mike's wife kelly out to
the mound to deliver tonight's
ceremonial first pitch
kelly will be throwing to david bell to
begin this twins reds two game series
the bell family baseball legacy is
incredibly special and we thank the bell
family for sharing mike with us
our baseball team and our organization
is better
having known mike bell here's jay happ
he's been better at home
struggle recently but a veteran guy
should
should know how to turn it around i'm
sure he's been searching for answers as
he wants to do well he wants to perform
and he wants to help this team get back
to 500 and start talking about the
playoffs again
see if india is going to be running here
three balls and two strikes
and hard center field him back
and making the catch on the edge of the
track almost overran the ball
the bullet to center field one away oh
i'm so glad we get to see this in person
again because
there's a collective groan from the you
know the fans in attendance that are
and even the ones that are still walking
to their seat it was like an oh this
ball's off the center field wall
he's shading him towards left center
field with two strikes and
the left hand hitter that ball is
tailing back towards the middle of the
field coming off his bat and
110 miles an hour and he ran that down
like it was a routine play
here's nick castiano's one hopper
fielded by arrives two down and the
runner stays at second base two down
indian second and tyler
stevenson the catcher driven to right
field
kepler is there to make the play and now
the home plate umpire lands barksdale is
going to come up
to jhap and make a quick check tyler
malley's been flying five wins and as
many starts he has been
dynamite in that time for the reds i've
been so impressed with
tyler malley it's been really good year
for him so here's
byron buxton playing at home for the
first time since coming back
oh buxton collapsed in the box his cleat
gave way
that probably could have been a bang
bang play but he fell square down right
at the plate
i think the twins are happy to see him
get up and finish his
jog to first base after the kind of
injury that he had every time he goes
down
you know they're worried well that's
some soft dirt in
the batter's box trevor larnak
swing of the miss strike three a blazing
96
mali's first k of the night and a one
two three
inning nelson cruz cruz left the ball
game yesterday with a bit of an
issue with his neck back in the lineup
today drilled to left field the neck and
everything else feels just fine
a home run for nelson cruz his 16th of
the year
there's just so much depth in this
lineup it's hard to navigate but
everybody's healthy when you've got
buxton at the top
you get through the first inning you
breathe a little sigh of relief and then
all of a sudden you look at
nelson cruz coming up to lead off the
next inning take a look at this there's
a reason he has 400 plus of them he
doesn't miss that one at 92
middle end he knew it right off the bat
117 miles an hour that ball was
absolutely crushed
i'd be ducking out of the way that too
you know people buy tickets in that
section hoping to get a home run ball
with not coming at you like that
girloff has the ability to roll that
ball in shortstop i feel like he's got
pretty good back control especially for
a young guy
they shift him we've seen him force the
ball through that way
the line drives center field a bench hit
an 02
single driving in kepler from third base
and it's two to nothing still nobody out
this was almost like he saw
the shortstop move on the other side of
the base and he almost got more
comfortable in the at-bat a guy who's
got
a good split change whatever you want to
call it slider yes he does have a good
fastball above average but he just kind
of sat back on this thing and just let
it travel and stayed on and
to me it looked like he had intent of
staying through the middle or even
staying through that part of the field
and he gave him the pitch to do it
capitalize and drove in a run twins up
by two early
three on one out bottom two
left field line deep to the corner
aquino chasing it
and he'll make the catch a foul ball
catch tagging from third and scoring
polanco makes it a three-nothing ball
game with two strikes
pretty good play to paris suarez stands
in he drew a walk in the second inning
2-2 pitch suarez swings and hammers one
deep left center field
way back and gone hey eugenio suarez a
two
run homer and the reds draw within one
it's three to two
two balls two strikes on aquino and
aquino drills that one
to left field and gone a tie game
back-to-back jacks from the reds it's
all
even three apiece that's why he's in the
lineup and that's why the reds are
anxious to get him back off the injured
list
bucks and bats oh boy and buxton hitting
the hand is going to run to first but
they will check on him that's
always such a vulnerable area and
he doesn't want any part of the trainer
coming out but they're going to check on
him this ball
running in he couldn't get away from it
and i got hit there once it doesn't feel
good
was not a glancing blow no that was
solid
do have the x-ray right down here in the
stadium hopefully he'll run up there at
some point and get a picture taken of it
or not but good sign that he looks like
he's gonna stay in the game
tied at three this won't help you sleep
tonight but byron buxton is out of the
game
nick gordon taking over in center field
buxton hit by a pitch
in the hand in the fourth inning and he
went out to play defense in the fifth
but now as we begin
the sixth inning nick gordon is out
there in center field
farrell out of the stretch nobody on and
a swing and a miss chased in the dirt
good pitch
and farrell gets the strikeout for out
number two well there's got to be a lot
to that we saw
suarez and his at-bat check swing on on
that same pitch and
in a 2-1 count here with two strikes
he's able to get him to chase
one ball two strikes farrell's one-two
on the way swung out and miss got him
came back with a breaking ball farrell
three up three now with a couple of
strikeouts
garrett way ahead of the count bases
loaded two outs two strikes
hard ground ball off garrett's cleat
gathers throws to first
and it's in time what recovery by
garrett on a comebacker that seemed to
get him in the foot
and he leaves him loaded here is in
drelton simmons with the bases loaded
and two away in the night
two and two chopped on the ground
india hit the force at second base extra
innings another bases loaded opportunity
squandered by the twins as reds bullpen
pitching
gets it done to the biggest spot here in
the temp
but you've got to know that the guy at
second base can score on a base hit
one bull two strike count castianos
over second into right center field base
hit freeman green light
he races home and the reds lead for the
first time today
nick castillanos delivers an rbi
single in the 10th inning 4-3
reds still only one out suarez aboard
three times tonight
and responsible for two out of the ribs
four runs
oh could he come up big right here
suarez in the air pretty deep right
field
caught near the wall castellano's tag
rbi
a you hadio suarez the sac fly expands
the lead
5-3 in the 10th that was needed let's
see if horiz can
get it going here in the 10th inning one
and two on arise
left center field neck one chasing it
he won't get there a run will score in
the time run
arise pulls into second base with an rbi
double
those other at-bats are done they're in
the past and the only one you have to
focus on is the one right now
and trying to get the job done high fly
left field
arise will set up for a tag should be
plenty deep to score him
the sacrifice fly and we're tied at five
to get him here
a 2-2 count to suarez got him shoemaker
with a scoreless 12 leaving the bases
full
3-1 count to miguel ceneaux 5-5
one out simmons the third 12th inning
high fly
left center field and miguel sano says
that's enough
twins win the game 7-5 on a walk-off
12th inning home run
from miguel cino